[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en la ciudad de lausana en Suiza donde
un equipo médico presentó al primer
paciente parapléjico de la historia que
pudo recuperar la movilidad de sus
piernas gracias a una especie de Puente
digital entre su cerebro y su médula
girl Jan Oscar sufrió un accidente hace
12 años su médula quedó afectada pero no
completamente cortada sin ánimo de
Rendirse hace dos años se puso en
contacto con este equipo de expertos que
empezó un largo proceso para ser parte
de un ensayo clínico con esta interfaz
There is one of the brain hacemos dos
cirugías una a nivel cerebral con dos
pequeñas craneotomías ponemos dos
electrodos para controlar la señal
cerebral y otra cirugía a nivel de la
médula espinal donde ponemos electrodos
en el lugar responsable del movimiento
de las piernas entre ellos hay
comunicación una comunicación eléctrica
un puente digital que reactiva las
piernas
lo primero que tuvo que hacer girt tras
recibir los implantes cerebrales que
vemos en pantalla fue durante meses
imaginarse moviendo las piernas esto
para que su cerebro emitiera estímulos
que eran leídos por algoritmos así logró
mover una versión digital de sí mismo lo
que llamamos un avatar esos estímulos
luego fueron transmitidos a la especie
de diadema que lleva en la cabeza esa
diadema transmite las ondas al portátil
que transporta en su caminador ese
portátil decodifica las ondas que son
transmitidas a la médula espinal y
generan el movimiento
pudo controlar el movimiento de su
músculo paralizado pero también tomó
mucho entrenamiento volver a ganar su
peso completo de pie volver a caminar
distancias largas
lo que observamos a lo largo de este
entrenamiento es una reparación digital
de la médula espinal no sólo pudo
aprovechar el puente digital para
controlar su músculo paralizado sino
para recuperar la función neurológica
que había perdido por muchos años lo que
sugiere que el puente digital promovió
el crecimiento de conexiones neuronales
connection los expertos explican que
para que el tratamiento sea exitoso se
requiere que el paciente tenga al menos
seis centímetros de la médula espinal
intactos para insertar los electrodos
que controlan el movimiento de las
extremidades y ya trabajan para lograr
que Esta técnica se pueda emplear con
personas que hayan perdido también la
movilidad desde los brazos Así mismo
podría ayudar a pacientes con parálisis
por accidentes cerebrovasculares
vamos ahora a Reino Unido porque una
compañía trabaja en cultivar bloques de
construcción modulares Y si hablamos de
cultivar es porque están hechos a partir
de hongos en un nuevo intento por
reducir las emisiones de la industria de
la construcción
sobre mi hombro derecho hay una
demostración de estos bloques de micelio
con micelio puedes crear la forma que
quieras pero sentimos que era importante
crear objetos que pudieran organizarse
apilarse en diferentes formas separarlos
y volverlos a unir casi como bloques de
Lego porque ese es uno de los aspectos
de la arquitectura del futuro hacer
edificios desmontables
hicimos un asiento hicimos una maceta
hicimos un pedazo de pared podemos hacer
todo tipo de formas si tenemos
suficientes bloques Y eso es lo que
tratamos de mostrar aquí
cabe recordar que la industria de la
construcción es responsable de alrededor
del 40% de las emisiones globales
principalmente por el uso del acero y
del hormigón Y estos arquitectos
aseguran que al hablar de sostenibilidad
y circularidad no tiene sentido seguir
construyendo edificios que en 50 años
tendrán que ser demolidos para edificar
nuevos estos bloques están hechos con
biocompuestos de micelio por lo que son
renovables biodegradables y según los
responsables el impacto ambiental es
mínimo Pero además tienen importantes
ventajas en aislamiento de sonido y son
altamente resistentes al fuego
estamos testeando la resistencia de los
bloques de micelio que hicimos pusimos
presión y peso y son muy resistentes es
aserrín cáñamo y lindos Unidos por
filamentos de frágiles filamentos de
micelio que por aparte no son
resistentes pero es la combinación de
esos materiales lo que le da la
resistencia
cambiamos de tema y ahora vamos a Egipto
donde arqueólogos descubrieron dos
talleres de embalsamamiento de animales
y humanos en la necrópolis de esa cara
además encontraron dos tumbas de
sacerdotes de aproximadamente
2.400 años que tienen sus ataduras
tallados con escenas de la época Ramiro
cuevarberena tiene los detalles
las pirámides de Egipto aún tienen
secretos por revelar tras un año de
excavaciones en la necrópolis de sakara
cerca del santuario de bastet que tenía
catacumbas con gatos momificados fueron
desenterrados talleres de momificación
humana y animal incluyendo las
herramientas que utilizaban los egipcios
en esos años
Esta es la primera vez que descubrimos
un taller de embalsamamiento asociado
con templos todos los talleres
anteriores estaban vinculados a
apisemensis lo que significa que es un
descubrimiento importante encontrar un
taller de embalsamamiento en Sahara
en tanto que también dieron que en el
arte de la época como una colección de
estatuas de madera y hallaron dos tumbas
de sacerdotes que tienen pinturas y
están talladas uno Data de la quinta
dinastía del reino Antiguo y el otro de
la dinastía decimoctava del reino tardío
alrededor de 2400 años atrás
vitcallman
las pinturas y las inscripciones de la
tumba son tan asombrosas representan la
vida religiosa y secular debido a sus
títulos podemos ver escenas de la
agricultura La cosecha el pastoreo la
matanza sacrificial y la cría de
animales todas esas escenas se
encuentran en la tumba el
calandora Egipto ha lanzado operaciones
arqueológicas en saqqara y otros lugares
antiguos en los últimos años con el fin
de revivir el turismo optado por la
agitación política de 2011 y logrando
descubrimientos de alto perfil
a sintonía
[Música]